cap vers l'est du village de fontenay le
comte où se cache une entreprise
familiale d'exception une chapellerie
haut de gamme qui fabrique des
couvre-chefs 100% paix main et 100% mais
d'une bande et toutes les couleurs tous
les tissus le chapeau
alors lequel vous préférés ici
chez les dents durant fabrique des
chapeaux depuis la fin du 19e siècle
et là j'ai rendez vous avec wilfrid la
cinquième génération suivez-moi pour
l'intelligent
qu'est ce que tu fais de beaux et bien
écoute l'on vient de sortir en fait une
nouvelle collection pour l'hiver
prochain que j'ai prises sur des anciens
patronage qui date de mon
arrière-grand-père là maintenant on a
fait un premier prototype
et ben si tu veux bien tu va
m'accompagner on va digitaliser en fait
le modèle patronage tchèque petit à
l'action donc là c'est le bourreau de
développement c'est là où on fait part
en fait toute la fabrication donc ça
c'était indispensable de moderniser
l'outil de production pour que justement
l'entreprise puisse faire durer oui tout
à fait c'était c'était un passage
obligatoire si on voulait faire face aux
nouvelles demandes et puis toujours sera
adapté pour nouveaux marchés etc
il fallait qu'on passe automatiquement
sur un outil beaucoup plus performant
que ce qu'on avait avant
et c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est quelque
chose de vraiment très intéressant parce
que c'est là où on comprend en fait
toute la base de la base de la casquette
ou du chapeau puis a plus de limites de
la créativité
non non c'est ce qu'on veut c'est un
façon le des limites après dans les
matières dont
dans l'effort mais c'est tard dans un
volume la mesure du possible voilà mais
c'est sûr qu'en termes de précision on
est beaucoup plus précis sur un écran
avec mon père à grandir la pièce on
travaille vraiment mm que sur du carton
comme on le faisait à l'époque
une fois que le patron de taxes futur
casquette a été entièrement digitalisé
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais qu'est ce
qui se passe on va sortir d'abord un
premier prototype
on va voir si le patronage de bon s'il
est accordé à la matière c'est ce que ça
nous a donné ici ça c'est un premier
proto de la c1 premier prototype yann
sortir on s'aperçoit qu'avec quelques
malfaçons donc là emmanuel va admirer
les premiers prototypes
elle va te dire là ça va pas du tout
hein c'est pas très régulier finalement
la forme correspond pas au résultat
qu'on souhaite obtenir ça du coup il
manque un petit peu un ou deux
millimètres avaient compris dans ce
concert t on
rien juste le modèle un ou deux
millimètres c'est vraiment de la
précision ça sur modaris on travaille au
demi millimètre près une fois que tout
prototype et enfin validé tu passes la
fabrication 3
voilà nathalie je vais te montrer
comment se passe en fait la coupe avant
d'utiliser donc les patronages carton
qui était coupé à la main sur des scies
à ruban à moderniser l'outil de
production et maintenance est coupée
automatiquement
c'est quoi c'est une découpe au laser
sont annoncées une découpe avec un
couteau c'est pas une découpe au laser
tu me demande comment ça serait sur
l'écran
bonjour
donc là sur l'écran en fait on va voir
chaque pièce qui est en train d'être
coupé d'accord donc chaque pièce qui est
en train de découper décider ici et dès
qu'elle passe au vert c'est qu'elles
étaient coupées et c'est un gain de
temps énorme à n'est pas dans es suzanne
ça se faisait à la scie à ruban ça se
faisait au couteau électrique et c'est
sûr que là et puis le matériel comme ça
et le fait de digitaliser donc les
patronages ça vous permet de gagner en
précision
une faute est découpée toutes les pièces
la couture ça se passe ailleurs se passe
de l'autre côté
voilà donc là je t'emmènerai ans marié
serait en fait qui est spécialisée dans
la broderie main
donc pour ce nouveau modèle en fait on a
fait une broderie machine avec les
initiales donc de la marque et marié
street va complètement rhdp relais en
fait le dessin pour donner plus de
dynamisme en fait à la broderie et du
poisson des plumes
c'est un travail titanesque à un travail
voilà un travail de précision très très
long il faut c'est avoir du goût pour
avoir de la sensibilité sur les baies
vitrées des choses une fois que lors de
mentation est terminée les bouton
pressoir ont été révélés
on passe à l'assemblage ou de la
casquette est ce que tu as ton avec le
centre pouvait ce travail et merci à
marc estève
c'est que ça se passe elles résident ou
la difficulté quand on monte une
casquette comme celle ci je veux du
centre la casquette pour demain que
j'aligne en fait messi côte
je me doutais ans et il faut avoir le
coup de marc foster un coude entre ces
traits épais ou en plus ça il faut à
l'aveuglé arrivé à jauger ou à ce qu'on
est au milieu comme si vous montez bio
gamme on peut pas se permettre d'avoir
un décalage et les savoir-faire ils
diffèrent en fonction du justement de la
forme du chapeau il ya des savoir-faire
sont différents il ya des personnes qui
ont des mains différentes sur telle ou
telle opération qui sont beaucoup plus à
l'aise sur certains opération que sur
d'autres dont 12 toute la difficulté de
pouvoir gérer une chaîne de fabrication
et faire l'équilibrage de redon
production et voilà qu'est ce qui se
passe alors ensuite tu vois une fois
qu'on a donc assemblé toutes les cotes
sur la casquette
après il ya d'autres petites opérations
va faire les surpiqûres de la casquette
comme ça on les voit ici tout à fait on
va poser deux boutons on va la mettre en
forme faire la visière les différents
éléments et après on va faire le montage
dont le montage d'une casquette je vais
te montrer ça tout de suite
ok c'est la dernière étape passée la
dernière étape de fabrication machines
d'assemblage
après on va passer sur du manuel donc la
mise en forme l'épluchage la
vérification etc il tue plein temps tout
est à peu près je dirais une dizaine
d'étapes où une dizaine de mains qui
vont passer sur l'imbrication d'une
casquette et cette maison elle n'est
jamais cédé aux sirènes de la
délocalisation jamais bien savoir faire
qu'elle français qui est historique
parce que plusieurs générations nous on
a vraiment capitaliser sur le savoir
faire et sur les compétences de nos
collaborateurs
c'est très important pour nous de se
dire on est bénie français en restera
milieu offensif merci bien maintenant
j'ai contré des étapes indiana et
bichonner allez c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est pas compliqué de faire aussi bien
que toi c'est juste le placement de la
casquette qu'il faut s'assurer que ce
soit bien sur l'arrondi de chauffage
comme ça exactement
et après tu fais comme ça c'est le
positionnement d'une main et l'autre ne
pouvoir justement appuyer le tissu est
bien le leur passé en gros mettre la
main wilfrid est ce que je travaille
bien
c'est pas trop mal peut-être que tu vas
pouvoir venir rejoindre l'équipe et
akuma apprendre c'est pas évident et
voilà et pour mettre en valeur ces beaux
chapeaux je me suis prêtée au jeu nacho
team photo improvisée entre les mains
expertes de wilfrid moi je vais sourire
regarde bien objectif tourner un petit
pain au four voilà oui oui il fait la
gazelle le gt john la chapellerie
dandurand encore une belle entreprise
récompensé en 2008 par l'obtention du
label entreprise du patrimoine vivant